2016년 11월 30일 새벽 2시
2016년 11월 30일 새벽 2시 대구의 밤하늘이 붉게 물들었습니다.
대구의 밤하늘이 붉게 물들었습니다.
대구의 밤하늘이 붉게 물들었습니다. 대한민국 3대 전통 시장으로 꼽히는
대한민국 3대 전통 시장으로 꼽히는
대한민국 3대 전통 시장으로 꼽히는 서문 시장에 불이 난 거죠. 무려
서문 시장에 불이 난 거죠. 무려
서문 시장에 불이 난 거죠. 무려 839개 전포가 전소되었고 피해액은
839개 전포가 전소되었고 피해액은
839개 전포가 전소되었고 피해액은 1,억 원을 훌쩍 넘겼습니다. 평생을
1,억 원을 훌쩍 넘겼습니다. 평생을
1,억 원을 훌쩍 넘겼습니다. 평생을 받쳐 읽은 삶의 터전니 하룻밤 사이에
받쳐 읽은 삶의 터전니 하룻밤 사이에
받쳐 읽은 삶의 터전니 하룻밤 사이에 제더미가 되어 버린 상인들의
제더미가 되어 버린 상인들의
제더미가 되어 버린 상인들의 망연자시란 모습 아직도 생생합니다.
망연자시란 모습 아직도 생생합니다.
망연자시란 모습 아직도 생생합니다. 그런데 말이죠. 이런 대형 화제가
그런데 말이죠. 이런 대형 화제가
그런데 말이죠. 이런 대형 화제가 전통 시장에서 유독 자주 발생한다는
전통 시장에서 유독 자주 발생한다는
전통 시장에서 유독 자주 발생한다는 사실 알고 계셨나요? 전통 시장은 왜
사실 알고 계셨나요? 전통 시장은 왜
사실 알고 계셨나요? 전통 시장은 왜 화재에 취약할까요? 소방청 통계에
화재에 취약할까요? 소방청 통계에
화재에 취약할까요? 소방청 통계에 따르면 2013년부터 2022년까지
따르면 2013년부터 2022년까지
따르면 2013년부터 2022년까지 10년간 전통 시장에서 발생한 화재는
10년간 전통 시장에서 발생한 화재는
10년간 전통 시장에서 발생한 화재는 총 509건이며 재산피해는 무려
총 509건이며 재산피해는 무려
총 509건이며 재산피해는 무려 1387억 원에 달합니다. 연평균
1387억 원에 달합니다. 연평균
1387억 원에 달합니다. 연평균 50일건의 화제가 발생하고 있는
50일건의 화제가 발생하고 있는
50일건의 화제가 발생하고 있는 셈이죠. 더 충격적인 사실은 전통시장
셈이죠. 더 충격적인 사실은 전통시장
셈이죠. 더 충격적인 사실은 전통시장 화재 한 건당 평균 피해 액기 약
화재 한 건당 평균 피해 액기 약
화재 한 건당 평균 피해 액기 약 4,300만 원으로 일반 화재의
4,300만 원으로 일반 화재의
4,300만 원으로 일반 화재의 2,400만 원보다 1.79배나
2,400만 원보다 1.79배나
2,400만 원보다 1.79배나 높다는 점입니다. 왜 이렇게 피해가
높다는 점입니다. 왜 이렇게 피해가
높다는 점입니다. 왜 이렇게 피해가 클까요? 바로 전통 시장의 구조적
클까요? 바로 전통 시장의 구조적
클까요? 바로 전통 시장의 구조적 특성 때문입니다. 소규모 전포가
특성 때문입니다. 소규모 전포가
특성 때문입니다. 소규모 전포가 다닥다닥 붙어 있고 천이나 원단처럼
다닥다닥 붙어 있고 천이나 원단처럼
다닥다닥 붙어 있고 천이나 원단처럼 불에 잘 타는 물건들이 빼곡히 쌓여
불에 잘 타는 물건들이 빼곡히 쌓여
불에 잘 타는 물건들이 빼곡히 쌓여 있죠. 여기에 수십년 된 노후 전기
있죠. 여기에 수십년 된 노후 전기
있죠. 여기에 수십년 된 노후 전기 시설까지 더해지면 불시 하나가
시설까지 더해지면 불시 하나가
시설까지 더해지면 불시 하나가 순식간에 대형 화제로 번질 수
순식간에 대형 화제로 번질 수
순식간에 대형 화제로 번질 수 있습니다. 실제로 화재 원인의
있습니다. 실제로 화재 원인의
있습니다. 실제로 화재 원인의 46.4%가 4%가 과전류나 전선
46.4%가 4%가 과전류나 전선
46.4%가 4%가 과전류나 전선 손상 같은 전기적 요인이었습니다.
손상 같은 전기적 요인이었습니다.
손상 같은 전기적 요인이었습니다. 특히 심야 시간대에 발생한 화재의
특히 심야 시간대에 발생한 화재의
특히 심야 시간대에 발생한 화재의 피해는 상상을 초월합니다. 자정부터
피해는 상상을 초월합니다. 자정부터
피해는 상상을 초월합니다. 자정부터 새벽 4시 사이에 발생한 화재 한
새벽 4시 사이에 발생한 화재 한
새벽 4시 사이에 발생한 화재 한 건당 재산 피해는 약 12억
건당 재산 피해는 약 12억
건당 재산 피해는 약 12억 7,800만 원으로 다른 시간대의
7,800만 원으로 다른 시간대의
7,800만 원으로 다른 시간대의 재산 피해보다 무려 47배나
재산 피해보다 무려 47배나
재산 피해보다 무려 47배나 높습니다. 상인들이 퇴근한 뒤라 화재
높습니다. 상인들이 퇴근한 뒤라 화재
높습니다. 상인들이 퇴근한 뒤라 화재 발견이 늦어지면서 대형 화제로 번지기
발견이 늦어지면서 대형 화제로 번지기
발견이 늦어지면서 대형 화제로 번지기 때문이죠. 그런데 여기서 주목할 점이
때문이죠. 그런데 여기서 주목할 점이
때문이죠. 그런데 여기서 주목할 점이 있어요. 전통시장 화재 공제라는 것에
있어요. 전통시장 화재 공제라는 것에
있어요. 전통시장 화재 공제라는 것에 가입했던 상인들은 신속하게 보상금을
가입했던 상인들은 신속하게 보상금을
가입했던 상인들은 신속하게 보상금을 받아 다시 장사를 시작할 수 있었다는
받아 다시 장사를 시작할 수 있었다는
받아 다시 장사를 시작할 수 있었다는 겁니다. 전통시장 화재 공제란 쉽게
겁니다. 전통시장 화재 공제란 쉽게
겁니다. 전통시장 화재 공제란 쉽게 말해 전통 시장 상인들이 조금씩 돈을
말해 전통 시장 상인들이 조금씩 돈을
말해 전통 시장 상인들이 조금씩 돈을 모아 공동의 재원을 만들고 화제가
모아 공동의 재원을 만들고 화제가
모아 공동의 재원을 만들고 화제가 발생하면이 돈으로 서로를 돕는
발생하면이 돈으로 서로를 돕는
발생하면이 돈으로 서로를 돕는 상부상조 시스템입니다. 정부가 사업
상부상조 시스템입니다. 정부가 사업
상부상조 시스템입니다. 정부가 사업 운영비를 지원하기 때문에 일반 민형
운영비를 지원하기 때문에 일반 민형
운영비를 지원하기 때문에 일반 민형 보험보다 훨씬 저렴하게 가입할 수
보험보다 훨씬 저렴하게 가입할 수
보험보다 훨씬 저렴하게 가입할 수 있다는게 가장 큰 장점이죠. 그럼
있다는게 가장 큰 장점이죠. 그럼
있다는게 가장 큰 장점이죠. 그럼 얼마나 보장받을 수 있을까요?
얼마나 보장받을 수 있을까요?
얼마나 보장받을 수 있을까요? 2025년 7월 16일부터 보상
2025년 7월 16일부터 보상
2025년 7월 16일부터 보상 한도가 대폭 확대되었는데요. 기존
한도가 대폭 확대되었는데요. 기존
한도가 대폭 확대되었는데요. 기존 6천만 원에서 1억 원으로 늘어난
6천만 원에서 1억 원으로 늘어난
6천만 원에서 1억 원으로 늘어난 거죠. 구체적으로 살펴보면 건물과
거죠. 구체적으로 살펴보면 건물과
거죠. 구체적으로 살펴보면 건물과 시설 집기에 5천만 원, 동산에
시설 집기에 5천만 원, 동산에
시설 집기에 5천만 원, 동산에 5천만 원까지 보장받을 수 있습니다.
5천만 원까지 보장받을 수 있습니다.
5천만 원까지 보장받을 수 있습니다. 그럼에도 공재료는 생각보다 부담이
그럼에도 공재료는 생각보다 부담이
그럼에도 공재료는 생각보다 부담이 적습니다. 1년 기준 최소 1만
적습니다. 1년 기준 최소 1만
적습니다. 1년 기준 최소 1만 원부터 주계약 보장 금액과 특약에
원부터 주계약 보장 금액과 특약에
원부터 주계약 보장 금액과 특약에 따라 선택적으로 가입할 수 있고 많은
따라 선택적으로 가입할 수 있고 많은
따라 선택적으로 가입할 수 있고 많은 지자체에서 공제료의 60에서 80%를
지자체에서 공제료의 60에서 80%를
지자체에서 공제료의 60에서 80%를 지원해 주기 때문에 실제 상인 부담은
지원해 주기 때문에 실제 상인 부담은
지원해 주기 때문에 실제 상인 부담은 더 줄어듭니다. 서울시의 경우 보장
더 줄어듭니다. 서울시의 경우 보장
더 줄어듭니다. 서울시의 경우 보장 금액 6천만 원 상품 가입시 연간
금액 6천만 원 상품 가입시 연간
금액 6천만 원 상품 가입시 연간 공제료 약 20만 원 중 80%인
공제료 약 20만 원 중 80%인
공제료 약 20만 원 중 80%인 16만3,000원을 지원받을 수
16만3,000원을 지원받을 수
16만3,000원을 지원받을 수 있죠. 거기다 2025년부터는 화상
있죠. 거기다 2025년부터는 화상
있죠. 거기다 2025년부터는 화상 및 5대 골절 수술 위로금 특약도
및 5대 골절 수술 위로금 특약도
및 5대 골절 수술 위로금 특약도 신설됐습니다. 추가 공제료 연
신설됐습니다. 추가 공제료 연
신설됐습니다. 추가 공제료 연 300원만 내면 1사고당 50만 원의
300원만 내면 1사고당 50만 원의
300원만 내면 1사고당 50만 원의 위로금을 받을 수 있어요. 음식물
위로금을 받을 수 있어요. 음식물
위로금을 받을 수 있어요. 음식물 배상 책임포 휴업 일단 같은 다양한
배상 책임포 휴업 일단 같은 다양한
배상 책임포 휴업 일단 같은 다양한 특약도 마련되어 있어 상황에 맞게
특약도 마련되어 있어 상황에 맞게
특약도 마련되어 있어 상황에 맞게 선택할 수 있습니다. 가입 자격은
선택할 수 있습니다. 가입 자격은
선택할 수 있습니다. 가입 자격은 간단합니다. 전통 시장 내에 전포가
간단합니다. 전통 시장 내에 전포가
간단합니다. 전통 시장 내에 전포가 있고 사업자 등록을 마친 상인이라면
있고 사업자 등록을 마친 상인이라면
있고 사업자 등록을 마친 상인이라면 누구나 가입할 수 있죠. 기존 민형
누구나 가입할 수 있죠. 기존 민형
누구나 가입할 수 있죠. 기존 민형 보험에서는 건물 구조에 따라
보험에서는 건물 구조에 따라
보험에서는 건물 구조에 따라 4등급으로 나눠 보험료를 다르게
4등급으로 나눠 보험료를 다르게
4등급으로 나눠 보험료를 다르게 책정했지만 화재 공제는 2등급으로
책정했지만 화재 공제는 2등급으로
책정했지만 화재 공제는 2등급으로 단순화해서 가입 문턱을 대폭
단순화해서 가입 문턱을 대폭
단순화해서 가입 문턱을 대폭 낮췄습니다. 공제 가입은 전통시장
낮췄습니다. 공제 가입은 전통시장
낮췄습니다. 공제 가입은 전통시장 화재 공제 홈페이지에서 직접
화재 공제 홈페이지에서 직접
화재 공제 홈페이지에서 직접 신청하거나 공단에서 지정한 공제
신청하거나 공단에서 지정한 공제
신청하거나 공단에서 지정한 공제 상담사를 통해 간편하게 가입할 수도
상담사를 통해 간편하게 가입할 수도
상담사를 통해 간편하게 가입할 수도 있습니다. 1년 2년 3년 중 기간을
있습니다. 1년 2년 3년 중 기간을
있습니다. 1년 2년 3년 중 기간을 선택할 수 있으며 장기 계약시 주계약
선택할 수 있으며 장기 계약시 주계약
선택할 수 있으며 장기 계약시 주계약 연간 공제료가 할인되는 혜택도
연간 공제료가 할인되는 혜택도
연간 공제료가 할인되는 혜택도 있습니다. 대구 성서용산 시장의
있습니다. 대구 성서용산 시장의
있습니다. 대구 성서용산 시장의 사례를 들어 볼게요.이 이 시장에서
사례를 들어 볼게요.이 이 시장에서
사례를 들어 볼게요.이 이 시장에서 화제가 발생했을 때 화재 알림 시설
화제가 발생했을 때 화재 알림 시설
화제가 발생했을 때 화재 알림 시설 덕분에 16분 만에 초동 진압이
덕분에 16분 만에 초동 진압이
덕분에 16분 만에 초동 진압이 완료됐습니다. 그리고 화재 공제에
완료됐습니다. 그리고 화재 공제에
완료됐습니다. 그리고 화재 공제에 가입해 둔 전포는 손실액 대부분을
가입해 둔 전포는 손실액 대부분을
가입해 둔 전포는 손실액 대부분을 보상받아 빠르게 생업에 복귀할 수
보상받아 빠르게 생업에 복귀할 수
보상받아 빠르게 생업에 복귀할 수 있었죠. 고성군 간성 시장의 사례도
있었죠. 고성군 간성 시장의 사례도
있었죠. 고성군 간성 시장의 사례도 있습니다. 평소처럼 음식을 조리에
있습니다. 평소처럼 음식을 조리에
있습니다. 평소처럼 음식을 조리에 팔았는데 단체 손님 여러 명이 식중독
팔았는데 단체 손님 여러 명이 식중독
팔았는데 단체 손님 여러 명이 식중독 증상을 일으키는 사고가 발생한
증상을 일으키는 사고가 발생한
증상을 일으키는 사고가 발생한 겁니다. 그런데 음식물 배상 책임
겁니다. 그런데 음식물 배상 책임
겁니다. 그런데 음식물 배상 책임 특약 덕분에 187만 원 이상을
특약 덕분에 187만 원 이상을
특약 덕분에 187만 원 이상을 보상받았습니다. 또 2024년 1월
보상받았습니다. 또 2024년 1월
보상받았습니다. 또 2024년 1월 양평군 양수리 전통 시장에서는 한
양평군 양수리 전통 시장에서는 한
양평군 양수리 전통 시장에서는 한 전포를 방문한 고객이 출입구 계단에서
전포를 방문한 고객이 출입구 계단에서
전포를 방문한 고객이 출입구 계단에서 넘어지는 사고가 발생했는데요. 다행히
넘어지는 사고가 발생했는데요. 다행히
넘어지는 사고가 발생했는데요. 다행히 화재 공제에 가입해 둔 덕분에 시설
화재 공제에 가입해 둔 덕분에 시설
화재 공제에 가입해 둔 덕분에 시설 소유자 관리자 배상 책임 보상 대상에
소유자 관리자 배상 책임 보상 대상에
소유자 관리자 배상 책임 보상 대상에 해당되어 약 750만 원의 공제금이
해당되어 약 750만 원의 공제금이
해당되어 약 750만 원의 공제금이 화재 공제를 통해 지급되었습니다.
화재 공제를 통해 지급되었습니다.
화재 공제를 통해 지급되었습니다. 화재뿐 아니라 전포 운영 중 발생할
화재뿐 아니라 전포 운영 중 발생할
화재뿐 아니라 전포 운영 중 발생할 수 있는 다양한 위험에도 대비할 수
수 있는 다양한 위험에도 대비할 수
수 있는 다양한 위험에도 대비할 수 있는 거죠. 화재 예방도 중요하지만
있는 거죠. 화재 예방도 중요하지만
있는 거죠. 화재 예방도 중요하지만 만약의 상황에 대비하는 것도 그만큼
만약의 상황에 대비하는 것도 그만큼
만약의 상황에 대비하는 것도 그만큼 중요합니다. 평생 땀 흘려 일군
중요합니다. 평생 땀 흘려 일군
중요합니다. 평생 땀 흘려 일군 가게가 하루 아침에 사라지는 비극
가게가 하루 아침에 사라지는 비극
가게가 하루 아침에 사라지는 비극 남의 일이 아닙니다. 전통시장 화재
남의 일이 아닙니다. 전통시장 화재
남의 일이 아닙니다. 전통시장 화재 공제는 그런 위기의 순간 다시 일어설
공제는 그런 위기의 순간 다시 일어설
공제는 그런 위기의 순간 다시 일어설 수 있는 힘을 주는 상인들의
수 있는 힘을 주는 상인들의
수 있는 힘을 주는 상인들의 안전망입니다. 하루 몇백 원의 투자로
안전망입니다. 하루 몇백 원의 투자로
안전망입니다. 하루 몇백 원의 투자로 내 가게와 가족의 미래를 지킬 수
내 가게와 가족의 미래를 지킬 수
내 가게와 가족의 미래를 지킬 수 있다면 충분히 가치 있는 선택
있다면 충분히 가치 있는 선택
있다면 충분히 가치 있는 선택 아닐까요?
아무 의심 없이 집어든이 음식들.
아무 의심 없이 집어든이 음식들. 우리 몸에 나트륨과 당이 얼마나
우리 몸에 나트륨과 당이 얼마나
우리 몸에 나트륨과 당이 얼마나 쌓이고 있는지 알고 계신가요?
쌓이고 있는지 알고 계신가요?
쌓이고 있는지 알고 계신가요? 나트륨과 당뇨를 과하게 섭취하면 우리
나트륨과 당뇨를 과하게 섭취하면 우리
나트륨과 당뇨를 과하게 섭취하면 우리 몸에도 부담이 쌓이고 고혈압이나 심장
몸에도 부담이 쌓이고 고혈압이나 심장
몸에도 부담이 쌓이고 고혈압이나 심장 질환, 당뇨병 같은 질병의 원인이 될
질환, 당뇨병 같은 질병의 원인이 될
질환, 당뇨병 같은 질병의 원인이 될 수 있습니다. [음악] 특히 성장기
수 있습니다. [음악] 특히 성장기
수 있습니다. [음악] 특히 성장기 청소년과 어린이들의 성장에도 영향을
청소년과 어린이들의 성장에도 영향을
청소년과 어린이들의 성장에도 영향을 줄 수 있으며 아무렇지 않게 선택한
줄 수 있으며 아무렇지 않게 선택한
줄 수 있으며 아무렇지 않게 선택한 음식 조합이 우리 몸에 부담이 되고
음식 조합이 우리 몸에 부담이 되고
음식 조합이 우리 몸에 부담이 되고 있을지도 모릅니다. 국물 컵라면
있을지도 모릅니다. 국물 컵라면
있을지도 모릅니다. 국물 컵라면 하나만 먹어도 하루 나트륨 권장량에
하나만 먹어도 하루 나트륨 권장량에
하나만 먹어도 하루 나트륨 권장량에 약 80%에 가까운 양입니다.
약 80%에 가까운 양입니다.
약 80%에 가까운 양입니다. 떡볶이는 약 100%에 가까운
떡볶이는 약 100%에 가까운
떡볶이는 약 100%에 가까운 수준입니다. 에너지 음료 한 캔만
수준입니다. 에너지 음료 한 캔만
수준입니다. 에너지 음료 한 캔만 마셔도 하루 당류 권장량의 약
마셔도 하루 당류 권장량의 약
마셔도 하루 당류 권장량의 약 60%에 해당합니다. 콜라 한켄도 약
60%에 해당합니다. 콜라 한켄도 약
60%에 해당합니다. 콜라 한켄도 약 40% 수준입니다. SNS에서 화제가
40% 수준입니다. SNS에서 화제가
40% 수준입니다. SNS에서 화제가 된 음식 조합들. 라면에 라면을 섞고
된 음식 조합들. 라면에 라면을 섞고
된 음식 조합들. 라면에 라면을 섞고 떡볶이에 핫발을 얹고 음료까지
떡볶이에 핫발을 얹고 음료까지
떡볶이에 핫발을 얹고 음료까지 곁드리는 편의점 레시피가 유행하고
곁드리는 편의점 레시피가 유행하고
곁드리는 편의점 레시피가 유행하고 있습니다. 맛있으니까 괜찮겠지?
있습니다. 맛있으니까 괜찮겠지?
있습니다. 맛있으니까 괜찮겠지? 그렇게 생각하기 쉽지만 한 번쯤은
그렇게 생각하기 쉽지만 한 번쯤은
그렇게 생각하기 쉽지만 한 번쯤은 멈춰서 생각해 볼 필요가 있습니다.
멈춰서 생각해 볼 필요가 있습니다.
멈춰서 생각해 볼 필요가 있습니다. 보기 좋고 맛있어 보인다고 해서
보기 좋고 맛있어 보인다고 해서
보기 좋고 맛있어 보인다고 해서 무조건 따라하기보다는 내 몸에 어떤
무조건 따라하기보다는 내 몸에 어떤
무조건 따라하기보다는 내 몸에 어떤 영향을 줄지 한 번 더 생각해
영향을 줄지 한 번 더 생각해
영향을 줄지 한 번 더 생각해 주세요. 우리 몸은 우리가 선택한
주세요. 우리 몸은 우리가 선택한
주세요. 우리 몸은 우리가 선택한 음식으로 만들어집니다.
요즘 우리 식탁 위에 대부분 음식은
요즘 우리 식탁 위에 대부분 음식은 말 그대로 첨가물의 완성입니다.
말 그대로 첨가물의 완성입니다.
말 그대로 첨가물의 완성입니다. 방부제, 색소, 향료, 유화제 이렇게
방부제, 색소, 향료, 유화제 이렇게
방부제, 색소, 향료, 유화제 이렇게 20개 이상의 화학 물질이 더해져야
20개 이상의 화학 물질이 더해져야
20개 이상의 화학 물질이 더해져야 겨우 만들어지는 음식들이 있죠.
겨우 만들어지는 음식들이 있죠.
겨우 만들어지는 음식들이 있죠. 이것을 우리는 초과공 식품이라고
이것을 우리는 초과공 식품이라고
이것을 우리는 초과공 식품이라고 부릅니다. 그런데 여기 재미있는
부릅니다. 그런데 여기 재미있는
부릅니다. 그런데 여기 재미있는 음식이 있습니다. 원료가 단 하나
음식이 있습니다. 원료가 단 하나
음식이 있습니다. 원료가 단 하나 그것도 순수한 원유뿐입니다. 바로
그것도 순수한 원유뿐입니다. 바로
그것도 순수한 원유뿐입니다. 바로 국산 우유의 정체입니다. 국산 우유는
국산 우유의 정체입니다. 국산 우유는
국산 우유의 정체입니다. 국산 우유는 착 후 바로 냉각되고 불필요한 외부
착 후 바로 냉각되고 불필요한 외부
착 후 바로 냉각되고 불필요한 외부 노출 없이 살균 처리만 거쳐서 단
노출 없이 살균 처리만 거쳐서 단
노출 없이 살균 처리만 거쳐서 단 2, 3일 내 식탁에 도착합니다.
2, 3일 내 식탁에 도착합니다.
2, 3일 내 식탁에 도착합니다. 유통 기한이 11일에서 14일로 짧은
유통 기한이 11일에서 14일로 짧은
유통 기한이 11일에서 14일로 짧은 이유가 바로 이것입니다. 가공이
이유가 바로 이것입니다. 가공이
이유가 바로 이것입니다. 가공이 적다는 것은 불안전함이 아니라 자연
적다는 것은 불안전함이 아니라 자연
적다는 것은 불안전함이 아니라 자연 그대로의 건강함의 증거입니다. 그래서
그대로의 건강함의 증거입니다. 그래서
그대로의 건강함의 증거입니다. 그래서 이제 거리의 과학을 봐야 합니다.
이제 거리의 과학을 봐야 합니다.
이제 거리의 과학을 봐야 합니다. 대양을 건너 들어오는 수입 멸균류는
대양을 건너 들어오는 수입 멸균류는
대양을 건너 들어오는 수입 멸균류는 최소 한 달 이상을 바다에서
최소 한 달 이상을 바다에서
최소 한 달 이상을 바다에서 보냅니다. 푸드마일리지가 길어지는
보냅니다. 푸드마일리지가 길어지는
보냅니다. 푸드마일리지가 길어지는 것이죠. 이동 거리가 길수록 영향은
것이죠. 이동 거리가 길수록 영향은
것이죠. 이동 거리가 길수록 영향은 손실되고 신선도는 떨어집니다. 반면
손실되고 신선도는 떨어집니다. 반면
손실되고 신선도는 떨어집니다. 반면 국산 우유는 가까운 거리, 빠른 유통
국산 우유는 가까운 거리, 빠른 유통
국산 우유는 가까운 거리, 빠른 유통 덕분에 신선도를 지킵니다. 그리고
덕분에 신선도를 지킵니다. 그리고
덕분에 신선도를 지킵니다. 그리고 수치가 말해 줍니다. 국내 원유
수치가 말해 줍니다. 국내 원유
수치가 말해 줍니다. 국내 원유 위생등급 기준은 최세포수 1등급
위생등급 기준은 최세포수 1등급
위생등급 기준은 최세포수 1등급 20만 개 미만, 세균수 1A등급
20만 개 미만, 세균수 1A등급
20만 개 미만, 세균수 1A등급 3만 개 미만입니다.이는 낭농선진국인
3만 개 미만입니다.이는 낭농선진국인
3만 개 미만입니다.이는 낭농선진국인 덴마크와 같은 수준이며 뉴질랜드와
덴마크와 같은 수준이며 뉴질랜드와
덴마크와 같은 수준이며 뉴질랜드와 네덜란드보다도 더 엄격한 기준입니다.
네덜란드보다도 더 엄격한 기준입니다.
네덜란드보다도 더 엄격한 기준입니다. 젖소의 건강 상태 위생, 저장
젖소의 건강 상태 위생, 저장
젖소의 건강 상태 위생, 저장 온도까지 모든 단계가 철저하게
온도까지 모든 단계가 철저하게
온도까지 모든 단계가 철저하게 관리되기에 가능한 수치입니다. 결국
관리되기에 가능한 수치입니다. 결국
관리되기에 가능한 수치입니다. 결국 신선함은 감각이 아닙니다. 그것은
신선함은 감각이 아닙니다. 그것은
신선함은 감각이 아닙니다. 그것은 과학으로 지켜낸 거리, 관리로 증명된
과학으로 지켜낸 거리, 관리로 증명된
과학으로 지켜낸 거리, 관리로 증명된 품질입니다. 우유 한잔이 식탁에
품질입니다. 우유 한잔이 식탁에
품질입니다. 우유 한잔이 식탁에 오기까지 그 거리와 그 관리가 만드는
오기까지 그 거리와 그 관리가 만드는
오기까지 그 거리와 그 관리가 만드는 신선함. 오늘의 신선남이 내일의 나를
신선함. 오늘의 신선남이 내일의 나를
신선함. 오늘의 신선남이 내일의 나를 지킵니다.